believe it or not this is how an
anarchist blows up balloons crush a
bunch of shells in a hydraulic press add
vinegar and the chemistry do it's
awesome thing this is an awesome
experiment I love to see this
demonstrated is so cool
this epic chemistry is the work of
Oregon's James or Gil but how is he
inflating balloons with shells James
is liberating carbon dioxide's has been
trapped in the seashells for years
mollusks begin to work on their shells
from a very early developmental stage
they secrete a special class of proteins
that acts almost like a scaffolding upon
which calcium carbonate is deposited
atmospheric carbon dioxide dissolves
into the water and eventually becomes
carbonate ions which then bind to
calcium ions that are already dissolved
in the water this calcium carbonate
forms the basis for the mollusks shell
calcium carbonate in the shells can
react with acetic acid in the vinegar to
create carbon dioxide by crushing them
he's increased their surface area so the
reaction happens quicker and this
releases carbon dioxide which is what
inflates the balloon when chemistry and
biology party it's a shell raiser